Situated on the border of Zambia and Zimbabwe,...
...the Victoria Falls rise 420 feet high and extend one mile wide.
Named in 1855 by Scottish explorer David Livingston after Queen Victoria,...
...the name locally of the falls translates into "the smoke that thunders."
Particularly unique and beautiful...
...because of the narrow chasm that the water falls into,...
...Victoria Falls is the largest single sheet of water in the world...
...with Niagara Falls pale in comparison.
Located about midway down the Zambezi River,...
...the chasm is about 400 feet wide...
...and was carved along a fracture in the Earth's crust.
Every minute, about 500 million liters of water go over the falls' edges.
And the fast force of all this falling water...
...creates spray that rises hundreds of feet into the air.